the mother and stepfather of an NSA
contractor accused of leaking government
secrets are speaking out about their
daughter 25 year old reality Lea winner
has been in federal custody since
Saturday the Air Force veteran faces up
to ten years in prison for allegedly
passing a classified document to a news
outlet winners family said she's not a
traitor
David beg note is in Augusta Georgia
outside the federal courthouse where she
will appear David good morning
you're a good morning reality winner and
that is her real name will appear here
in federal court for the second time in
a little more than 24 hours from now
right now she is being held in the
county jail on espionage charges her
parents who she actually called as the
FBI was in the process of arresting her
got in their car and drove from Texas to
Georgia to feed her cat and then they
decided we want to speak out on her
behalf I know that she's scared she is
scared that they won't let her out her
daughter reality ly winner is now the
defendant in the Trump administration's
first criminal leak case Billie Jean
Davis says the 25 year old was
frightened by her arrest last Saturday
her words to me were that she was really
scared that they would make her
disappear the Department of Justice says
winner admitted to taking a top-secret
intelligence document dated May 5th
which details hacking by the Russian
military intelligence the government
claims the win winner retained and
transmitted classified national defense
information she could have compromised
the security of the United States I'm
terrified I'm terrified that she's not
gonna be treated fairly and that they're
gonna try to make it an example of her
and that's not fair sorry winner was
active on social media up until the day
of her arrest tweeting under the
pseudonym Sarah winners she expressed
disappointment from the election results
and her disdain for President Trump
she used the hashtag not my president
several times
winners court-appointed attorney Titus
Nichols says his client plans to enter a
not guilty plea tomorrow we have the
burden of showing that my client is not
a risk of committing new offenses that
she's not a risk of fleam as a
contractor at an NSA facility in Augusta
Georgia
is among the 1.3 million people who have
top-secret security clearances she
serves six years with the US Air Force
and received a commendation medal
she's a patriot her stepfather says the
charges she's facing are an insult to
her and her service
she served her nation with distinguished
honor and that's that's who reality
winner is it's not the person that
they're being portrayed she is winner
she is she's she's our winner a winner
so the FBI says that a crease and the
piece of paper that reality winner
actually mailed to the intercept media
outlet revealed where the printout came
from computer experts say these days
color printers can reveal a lot about
the printing you're making and Gale it's
done through micro dots on the piece of
paper they are actually invisible to the
naked eye but they can reveal the
computer server number and the date and
time you press print Wow David that's a
very interesting little detailed nugget
there thank you so much we'll talk to
you a little bit later on